this is not my normal content
but with the end of Vanderpump Rules original cast coming to an end
I wanna talk about Lala Kent for a second
because I think she had one of the most interesting and relatable story arcs
on this entire show and I think
although it didn't start out this way
and obviously it wasn't her intention
it really serves as a cautionary tale to younger women about pick me behaviour
and I don't say that to judge
because I see a lot of similar behaviours in myself in my early 20s
because Lala Kent was not the only woman
who was taught the how to keep a man mentality
you know if you look good and you're agreeable
your husband won't leave you right
as long as you're sexually adventurous and open
and not like that nagging ex of his who never appreciated things he did
he will treat you well and at one point or another
we all believe that that is true
Lala moved heaven and earth to be fun and cute and young and agreeable
and sexually adventurous and super spontaneous
and to help him take care of his step kids and his home
and guess what a scumbag was always gonna be a scumbag
and that's because
and that's because a good and loyal man is not a reward for good behaviour
it has to do with integrity and how they value their partner
you know I know the old saying is that you can't turn a hoe into a housewife
but you can definitely turn a hoe into a housewife
more often than you can turn a scumbag into a saint
so the cautionary tale in Lala's story
is not that you can't turn a hoe into a housewife
because she did and she was successful at it
is that if a man treats women and his female partners like a commodity
and has proven that in his ex relationship
or blames the ending or cheating on his last relationship
on something that the woman did performance wise
it's that you will never be good enough to change a man from his true nature
cause there's nothing in your power that you can do to keep a man
who's always looking over the fence to see what's next
and I just wish Lala the best in this new chapter of life